now yeah that's not entirely
absolutely 100 percent
factual yes and i have confessed
to more educated audiences and i will do
so again
i was intrigued by dieter's house that
when you enter the house there are seven
or eight
oil paintings of open doors and i asked
him dida why do we have that sort of
images and he
he couldn't really answer it and he said
yeah i kind of like that and open doors
and i like to have a
an open view and i realized that that it
was
a very very deep metaphor for
him in in this unbelievable
drama of his captivity and
the ordeal he has gone through liberty
meant to be able to open and close the
door
and i invented and i asked him deiter
you s you you bang your car door two or
three times and open and close the door
a couple of times for us for the camera
and you kind of
see that that he is a little bit shy
about it and and he becomes very
sympathetic
through that you even though you have no
idea of the film
you started to laugh and you laugh in
appreciation
you immediately have a warm feeling
about him
and and it's totally invented totally
staged
and yet with a background of the
pictures that he has
right inside the door open doors
looks into an an open free space
is is an essence of of what constitutes
data
and that's exactly what i mean by
factually
it even the the accountants would even
tell me yes this is fake this is a lie
yes it is a lie it is a fabrication
but for it is forgery but for the sake
of a much deeper truth
so it is it is um
it is false or it's fake and it's
fabrication
and yet it is a deep poetic truth about
him
and that's what what i what i try to
defend and that's why i am against
cinema verity and
that's why i'm against the superficial
sort of stuff that you see
day after day after day on television
i just get sick and tired of it and we
have to find means
to to find this uh the deeper truth that
is possible on
on film there is something that that
we should work on and and that's why the
gauntlet is thrown down
and that's why i go into such wild
rambling statements like
like the the we ought to be grateful
that the universe out there knows no
smile
so it and it's it has nothing to do with
with truth in fact in cinema and yet it
is connected because that is a poetic
truth
and that's against all the all the
political correctness of those who
who are the lovers of these phony lovers
of mother nature
and and eat the vitamin pills
in pound after pound and
and do yes i'm against them and you may
whistle as much as you want
i i like to have you as my enemy out
there
and we can meet later in the men's room
and sort things out
but i but i think we have to voice
somehow i
needed to voice my my concern and i
needed to
to to state certain things that have
been
in in turmoil inside of me and this
the manifesto i think is is something
that
that should stay in in your hands as a
souvenir of this
of this evening and i gladly hand it
over uh
to you and and and uh bite
on on these nuts as much as you as you
want and
and and and disagree with it as much as
you want
that's fine i i'm not
a biblical prophet out there i'm i'm
just
struggling to to do something for the
sake of cinema and for the sake of
audiences and for the sake of
illumination that is possible
in when you sit in in front of a screen
and you do hopefully i i don't know i
sometimes i i have some doubts but
whatever i had some more questions but
what you just said seems like
a summation a dramatic
kind of apolog forget that word
apologia or justification because
it's true if you had a shot of him
opening the door going inside and
closing it you would have a shot of him
opening the door going inside and
closing it
what we have here is a shot of dieter's
soul
yes and we know him and excuse me
that didn't like him he thought dieter
thought yeah i
my friends will will dislike me and they
said no no no no
they will like you even better they will
love you
they will love you for this they will
love you for your hesitation they will
love you for
for your clumsiness i will love you for
for
for all this and it is true people like
him for that
people are